gillette's controversial new ad is
raising questions about what masculinity
means in the metoo era
the ad addresses issues including
bullying sexual harassment
and toxic masculinity bullying
the me too movement against sexual toxic
masculinity for sure
is this the best a man can get
[Music]
is it the ad already has nearly 20
million views on youtube and the
reaction
is divided the video got more than 500
000 likes complete
compared to nearly 1 million dislikes
ted bunch is the co-founder of the
advocacy group a call to men
which aims to shift attitudes and
behaviors against women and marginalized
groups
and lisa demour is a psychologist and
cbs news contributor
her upcoming book is called under
pression under pressure pardon me
confronting the epidemic of stress and
anxiety in girls
good morning good morning you both good
morning so uh ted what do you make of
the
ad and the backlash to it well we
support the ad
a call to man's been in existence for 16
years and
very much this ad is very much in line
with the work that we do
and i think what's um misunderstood by
the backlash is that this is not an
indictment on manhood it's actually an
invitation to men to be different to be
better and don't all of us want to be
better
yeah so i think the backlash has a lot
to do with it also challenges you know
in this post me too
era you know men have been challenged to
reflect um to challenge our privilege
our entitlements
to look at how we impact other people
and that's what this this ad does also
and the fact of the matter is men do
talk over women in boardrooms men
are sexually harassing at rampant uh
rates
um it doesn't speak to all the violence
that men perpetrate toward women either
but what's important to say when we talk
about violence in particular
is that while the overwhelming majority
of violence against women and girls is
men's violence overwhelming majority of
men
are not violent but we're silent about
those that are and that's as much of the
problem so
that's why that line in there men need
to hold other men
accountable so lisa as a psychologist
what is the science what does the
research tell us about
notions of masculinity well it tells us
a lot of different things one is that
being a man in this culture comes with
an extra measure of power
right so then this question about what
to do with that power comes up
so to go off of what ted was saying men
can either use that power to be violent
or sexist or they can use that power to
stick up for people who have less power
to be positive leaders
in terms of the science of extremes of
masculinity you know ultra macho
behavior
it turns out that that is bad both for
mental health and physical health
in terms of mental health it is harmful
to be denied the full range of human
emotional experience
everybody is sad everybody gets scared
if you're not allowed those feelings
they come out sideways
is it possible do you think both of you
to teach toughness without toxicity
absolutely i think that there's a lot to
be said both for women and for men to
find the ways that they
can stand up for themselves and others
in ways that are respectful and safe
and where does it start sorry go ahead
well it starts with
our collective socialization of manhood
how we pass down from one generation to
the other
these lessons of manhood and we have
this concept that addresses the
collective socialization of manhood
called the man box it's supposed to be
tough don't ask for help
uh don't show fear show no emotion no no
emotion
except for anger and anger is actually a
secondary emotion we're feeling sadness
and pain but we don't get to show that
we have to bring it up through anger
because when we do show that we're
ridiculed as that little boy when we
tell that little boy to stop crying
we're also telling him to stop feeling
so as we grow this man box also teaches
us that women and girls have less value
than men and boys that women are the
property of men that women
and girls are sexual objects that's what
that's our collective socialization
we're all taught that on some level
doesn't mean we act out on it in any
negative way
all of us or but some of us do so
um when we talk about even the the
backlash as we mentioned you know this
is the first generation of men being
held accountable
for something men have always gotten
away with it's a paradigm shift we're
not we don't
we haven't figured it out we don't know
how to navigate it yet so we want to
push back
and how we often push back is by kind of
blaming women
for what's going on for men whether it's
sexual harassment or workplace oh i'm
not going to have a closed door meeting
with a woman
as if when doors were closed women were
doing things that were inappropriate
it was men who were doing those things
so we switch up
lisa where do young men now though learn
about masculinity because it's different
than an older generation of men
which is part of what some of the
complexity of this conversation's about
so i think it starts with cueing from
the culture
you know they see what's on the media
they see what's around them but a huge
amount of it comes from how they police
one another
you know to be a boy at school is to be
part of a very heavily policing
of not acting like a girl it's not so
much about being a certain kind of boy
it's not being a girl
and then those boys decide what
girl-like behavior might be so it might
be
crying it might be taking school
seriously it might be being into arts
anything that gets dubbed girlish is
then off the table
so part of how we need to intervene is
to talk with young boys
about their policing of one another but
in a way that doesn't invite a defensive
response
i think that part of how we need to
enter into this entire conversation
is to not make people feel under attack
because then you can't be part of the
conversation i almost think you should
ban the phrase boys will be boys because
that seems to give them a pass or you're
acting like a girl
which is quite often interpreted as a
negative thing it's a code for a naughty
but yeah
sounds also like what you're saying is
to ban toxic masculinity which suggests
there's something inherently in being a
man
that makes you toxic i i think that is a
very charged
term and as a psychologist it
once you throw something like that down
it is very hard to engage the people you
need to engage in a conversation kids
are receptive at a very early age but
we're not toxic
as men you know we've learned some
behaviors that are harmful not only to
women
and children but to men and boys and
those who don't conform to gender at all
so it's not
that we're toxic that's right yeah thank
you both yeah good conversation
and i say kudos to gillette for starting
this conversation thank you guys i
didn't understand the backlash but i'm
in the minority on that
thank you both thank you thanks